hey Ron i'ma be sharp welcome to Abby's
kitchen Spring has finally sprung and
that means we are all looking for really
great fresh colorful recipes to start
our day so today I want to share with
you one of my favorite recipes from the
mindful Glo cookbook if you don't have
this book folks be sure to get it you'll
see the link below in the description
but we're going to be doing a
traditional egg base recipe because I
know Easter is coming and a lot of you
are looking for egg recipes but for my
plant-based friends and followers out
there we're gonna be making this
completely plant-based so this is my
sweet potato and black bean scramble
breakfast taco with tomatillo salsa it
is so fun it's so colorful and it's a
kind of percent vegan so you guys are
going to love it let's do that to a pan
I add a little bit of olive oil over
medium-high heat and then I add some
diced sweet potatoes and give it a good
stir until they all start to brown then
I add a can of rinsed black beans maple
syrup Chipotle and adobo sauce cumin and
cinnamon and I start to cook everything
into the sweet potato soften then I set
them aside and keep them more next to
the pan I add a little more olive oil
along with some firm tofu then I add
some turmeric and some nutritional yeast
along with a pinch of salt and I give
that a good stir and cook it until the
tofu gets nice and yellow to assemble I
layer some corn tortillas with my tofu
my sweet potato black bean mixture
some avocado some tomatillo salsa that
you're gonna need to get a copy of the
mindflow cookbook to get some crumbled
feta cheese vegan or not cilantro and
some lime enjoy
[Music]
[Music]